they celebrate that 33 to nothing
victory by sending a second-round pick
to the Falcons for receiver Mohamed Sanu
I thought they'd make a run at AJ green
maybe they did
maybe the Bengals wanted more than what
the Patriots would offer maybe the
Bengals are just stubbornly gonna hold
on to AJ Green
but it's anew the guy who was the
forgotten man in Atlanta the Falcons
Peter have to be thrilled with getting a
second-round pick from Mohamed Sanu and
getting that contract off their books
and now the Patriots have another piece
in the machine
this collection of guys who none of them
are spectacular but collectively they're
going to provide Tom Brady with at least
one open man on any given play Mike I'd
rather have Mohamed Sanu than AJ green
right now for the rest of this year
and I know that everybody's gonna say
what are you talking about first of all
you know he's cheaper he's gonna be less
expensive to acquire and I can trust him
health-wise I can't trust AJ Green
health-wise and so I want somebody who
I'm pretty sure is gonna line up and
play for the next nine games in the
regular season of whatever we have in
the playoffs I think number two that
Greg Schiano will tell who's there is no
person in coaching other than maybe Nick
Saban and the guys who are on his staff
right now there's no person in coaching
whose opinion Bill Belichick respects as
much as Greg Schiano
I am sure over the years or even maybe
yesterday or last week that Greg Schiano
told Belichick get this guy at all costs
the other thing he allows the Patriots
to do that everybody you know is gonna
say oh well that's never gonna happen
it might only happen once it might not
happen at all but here is the thing that
Mohamed Sanu allows you to do he allows
you to make the trick play at a huge
time in a huge game when nobody is
expecting it he's a great thrower of the
football his first six passes in NFL
games he completed him he completed all
of them and in my opinion part of this I
mean look at that spiral
that ball goes 50 yards in the air and
and so I just think that he does a lot
of things that are gonna help this team
right now
no question he's got great versatility
yes the trick plays the throws I've seen
it in person he can really throw the
football we talked a little bit about
this the first hour Peter he's he's
somebody that has worked with my my
family before as far as catching
footballs and we've seen him throw and
he can launch it but the versatility you
talk about I think is the beauty of it
you know now you got guys with Julian
Edelman J and of course Josh Gordon when
he does get healthy but Mohamed Sanu who
can really do everything as far as you
just can't peg them to one thing and
sinew is a great run blocker he's really
physical over the middle he can break
tackles after he catches the ball and do
those type of things so he fits that New
England way as far as what they're
expecting out of that position and I
think that's what probably fancied the
the Patriots to want to get him as well
and it's not just the fact that sinew
can throw the ball that threat is there
now both from sinew and from Edelman and
you can never really fully relax on that
possibility that may be the thing that
freezes a guy for a split second he
thinks he sees a look that suggests
sinews gonna get the ball and throw it
and he didn't but then the guy he's
supposed to cover is running right by
him and and that's the beauty of this as
well and the rich keep getting richer
and this one does surprise me though the
compensation is significant even though
it will be at the bottom around two
that's a lot to give up from a Hobbit's
anew but they've wanted him and it's
been obvious they've wanted help with
the position and even though it's not a
guy who's gonna command double coverage
everywhere he goes Peter it fits into
what we were talking about last hour as
well they never have they had four
Antonio Brown for one game but they
rarely have in recent years in New
England one receiver who just has that
personality that's gonna suck up all the
footballs and you have to feel compelled
to get in the ball and get him involved
like Odell Beckham jr. it's just another
piece of the puzzle and Tom Brady said
after the game last night when he was
talking about Jacoby Myers the undrafted
rookie who had four catches last night
and five the week before I just throw
the ball the open man and sinew allows
them to continue that it gives him
another guy who's gonna be open and
Brady's gonna know when these guys
he's gonna throw him the ball nobody's
ever gonna complain and that's the best
way to run this offense Mike I was the
pool reporter at the Super Bowl before
the Falcons Patriots Super Bowl covering
Falcons practices and that week the one
thing I noticed about the about the
Falcons okay that was a Kyle Shanahan
coached offense and I sensed you know
that that in that offense at that time
obviously Julio Jones is going to get
the bulk of the looks for Matt Ryan I'm
sure that in the course of an average
game Ryan is gonna look at him at least
15 times but the one thing about that
about those three practices that I
watched is that Sanu is a worker bee who
is not at all cocky or hey give me the
ball you know he just was hey wherever
I'm supposed to be I'm gonna be there's
no emotion if I get it there's no
emotion if I don't get it to me that is
the kind of mentality that's gonna fit
in well with the Patriots yeah that's
exactly the mentality at every Patriots
receiver who thrives they're ultimately
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports